we've been talking about the global
crunch in energy supplies in recent
weeks now turkey is feeling the strain
ankara has ordered its biggest gas
consumers among them electricity
producers in large factories to scale
back massively for three days
in effect that means power outages and
stoppages on factory floors
now behind the decision is a supply
problem in iran that's the source of
about 16 percent of gas supplies going
into turkey
iran stopped gas flows to the country
for 10 days citing a technical problem
on its end
its own gas consumption has meanwhile
jumped due to cold temperatures
in turkey local and international
companies are suffering from turkish car
maker tofas to french car maker renault
which is shutting down production for
two weeks
but not all companies can simply shut
off look at this tilo paul managing
director of the german chamber of
commerce in istanbul warned that
industrial plants can't simply switch
off many of them without damaging
technically sensitive systems including
blast furnaces
now that can cost millions all of this
coming meanwhile with turkey in the
middle of an economic slump
now for more on this let's go to our dw
correspondent in istanbul yulia han
julia good to see you how serious is
this outage hitting turkish businesses
well similar gas supply cuts stephen
have happened here in turkey in the past
but they did not lead to power outages
in the industrial sector on such a great
scale this is turkey's worst energy
crunch in decades experts are saying the
government imposed a three-day energy
cut on hundreds of industrial zones here
in the country multiple companies have
announced disruptions or stop production
entirely not only in the car industry
but also in the textile sector in iron
glass steel production and so on so if
these companies can't produce even if
it's just for three days
they fear they will not be able to
fulfill their export commitments so
exports are threatened and this could
potentially also affect international
markets like the european market
all right so turkey has ordered that
crunch and supplies for three days iran
meanwhile saying that it needs 10 days
to solve its problem what is turkey
going to do in the meantime
well the government has to try to solve
this because the fear here in the
country right now is apart from the
obvious economic and financial damage
that the blackouts and the gas supply
restrictions could also affect
households although the government has
pledged that wouldn't be the case now
officials from the state-run turkish
pipeline company botash have been sent
on an emergency mission to tehran to
try to resolve this stoppage but you
have to know that these disruptions
really come at a very delicate time for
turkey demand for energy has skyrockets
especially skyrocketed especially now
that it's a winter but the turkish
currency the lira has weakened very
badly against the dollar and the euro so
imports of energy have become very very
expensive both for the industry and for
households
you know gas supplies are in high demand
right now around the world that's
probably only going to increase in the
years ahead with a transition for many
countries is this prompting any kind of
a rethink for ankara
well this is what experts and government
critics have been demanding in recent
days highlighting that turkey is nearly
fully dependent on imports gas imports
from azerbaijan russia and iran so these
experts are basically saying that turkey
has to diversify energy suppliers
increase energy efficiency improve
storage or develop alternative energy
resources so what they are saying is the
government has to be prepared much
better for future out outages
all right yulia hahn in istanbul thank
you very much